welcome to this video if a new week is
starting and I thought about what the
theme might be for that week I want to
do another themed week and I'm going for
offbeat openings yeah so it's a very
general kind of theme but it's difficult
yeah you cannot really say okay let's do
this and that because you cannot force
the opponent to do something and I think
this this thing like offbeat openings is
a good it has a good compromise on so
play a little bit yeah out of the normal
things but not make it to specific that
and then then you have problems to
really get it on the board okay so we
got the electrons defense and I really
have to make it up here as long as I go
I don't know the theory here at all
against a form yeah let's see i thought
i might get the palm back here okay six
yeah well okay don't think that this is
any good for what i would get c5 i guess
i don't know if this is really
compensation for the pawn might be but
black shouldn't be in bad shape
okay so night c 50 also has this little
night b3 trick yeah which you overlooked
but is it how good is it that's the
problem might be 3a be Queen a 1 let us
go for it it's not entirely clear check
I have zero development almost zero
yeah one of those am Bishop t1 or
naughty one and canceling next I guess
so i'm going to go back here get the
Queen back into the game
your whites compensation is certainly
not sufficient in a purely theoretical
sense but it is a it is blitz chess all
kinds of crazy things might happen how
do I I no no I almost get queen strated
queen bee sexy singer here C Phi okay
what is he up to 92 95 or something
let's put this out for Luke the eighth
ok so night 95 or what probably
now if I back in play age 60 i want to
just send him back and I'll show about
it but my rooks are reasonably active
and don't see a particularly great thing
for him okay like this 594 maybe I can
also go to h5 with the Queen maybe go
there hmm but that means h5 wasn't
really threatened so i'm not sure if i
needed to do that but maybe I have Queen
g4 and possibly queen air for this kind
of thing check
yeah I need to get the King out of the
diagonal or pen King g8 is the next move
pretty much no matter what knocking here
I'm going to return the exchange just
for the just for this position this is
just very nice now so checking on g3
your check that's nice check on the age
three even a 94 is also good the chat
simple right thank you for check running
into big white discovered checks so that
was the first one of this off of the
offbeat week the electrons defense and
it got me got me a wind down I really
have no idea about this so let's see how
about that this is a move i recently saw
in a game played by a teammate of mine
but i don't know how it continued we
don't know why this this this makes some
sense yeah attacking the center there I
don't know what I was thinking that even
this is probably interesting yeah this
may be for Knight f3 next I really don't
know okay it takes and now we just ditch
the pawn okay yeah I don't know I mean
white will probably lose the c5 point do
you really have compensation for that
porn maybe but I'm really not sure yeah
this is threatening that be through
which you just ignored I think I have to
take that there is no no real
compensation for the for the whole thing
on the pawn
I think I'm basically just just an
exchange of yeah let's get developed I
think this that was not the best
according to the comp but now it's not a
big difference but it looks it looks
fine yeah now e5 494 Queen h5 is
probably not the most accurate move but
it is ok I was always ready to to do
something like that yeah return some
self and then let's say something like
this that looks very safe gather rook is
protecting here night is protecting e7
and I don't really see his compensation
minus 3 by the comp that's a bit bit
much yeah but it's just seem to be any
attack and TR ok 3 is just it's just a
good thing to continue you have two
points now and black is actually on the
attack so I think that was a good good
choice making things simple yeah good
starting game Mia for the offbeat wheat
week thanks for watching